j'accueille maintenant gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
c'est la caméra
joyeux anniversaire
joyeux
anniversaire
joyeuse année
hier serge françois
joyeux anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
bah oui c
était obligé de faire un truc 30 entre
canal+ et la mi mandat pour le chef du
village gaulois qui résiste encore et
toujours aux sondages positifs ces deux
ans et demi au top du fonds coincé
alors selon un sondage 86 % des français
ne souhaitent pas qu'il se représente en
2017 les 14 % restants ont dit non non
j'ai déjà une freebox
et je sais pas quoi faire de lui en ce
moment il voyage beaucoup c'est normal
ils cherchent une terre d'asile il
vérifié prépare sa fuite de varennes
quoi c'est comme ça sauf qu'à la
différence de louis saez qu'on a reconnu
à cause d'une pièce de monnaie hollande
il va se faire choper grâce un vieil
exemplaire de closer
[Applaudissements]
elle traque au canada il aurait déclaré
c'est à moi de faire comprendre aux
français à quel point ils sont forts
et c'est à ce genre de détail que tu dis
que les stucs ferme les yeux sur ce qui
se passe à l'elysée
autre actualité de la semaine montebourg
qui retournent à l'école alors en fait
pour lui le passage par bertie c'était
juste un bizutage j'étais sans coupe du
monde pour dans une école de commerce je
vois déjà le désastre élèves montebourg
pourriez vous me dire quels sont les
secteurs d'avenir pour l'économie bien
sûr la sidérurgie et des mines de
charbon
mais je pense que je pense c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont pris à l'insee être parce que
montebourg ça va être la poule aux oeufs
d'or parfaite à 34 1500 euros les 4
semaines puis son incompétence ils
tiennent un multi redoublant super
rentable
le ministre de l'économie qui retournent
à l'école c'est comme si mark zuckerberg
décidé de prendre des cours pour
s'initier à internet pourquoi elle est
en fait j'ai pas son poster
est en fait il y a qu'en france que
foutent là est possible si c'est quand
même le seul pays où le stagiaire dirige
la boîte avant de s'occuper des cafés de
la photocopieuse
immobilier syndical alors le logement de
fonction du chef de la cgt a fait
polémique quoi alors je me suis procuré
la liste des travaux effectués dans
l'appartement parce que bien sûr on fait
un travail de journaliste
alors quand j'ai lu toile est facturé à
4400 53 euros c'est normal c'est quand
même son bureau
a vu la diarrhée verbale de la cgt bah
ouais
affaires tournesol enfin le barrage de
civens je sais pas comment deux experts
indépendants ont sorti un rapport qui
dit le barrage c'est pas une bonne idée
les calculs sont erronés mais c'est
impossible d'arrêter les travaux on
dirait un résumé du travail de hollande
à mi-mandat
route du rhum à peine parti déjà dix
bateaux qui ont coulé apparemment vu le
nombre d'abandons dès le départ je crois
que les compétiteurs ont pris au pied de
la lettre le titre de la course
non mais enfin
quand même se prendre un cargo avec un
catamaran en plein golfe de gascogne sur
le bassin de la villette sur le lac du
bois de vincennes je veux bien
et se prendre un cargo dans l'océan se
dire c'est quand même posséder ce talent
rare de rouler plein pot dans le désert
et te manger le seul palmiers de la
seule oasis
[Applaudissements]
alors non tout de suite là un truc
beaucoup plus dans la lignée de enfin
lors de way un homme éjacule sur 5 oui
voilà
un homme éjacule sur sa fac trice oui
elle a été prise en charge par les
pompiers brièvement hospitalisée faut la
comprendre on est en état de choc le
calaisis et l'a dit mais vous vous
rendez compte c'était même pas mon père
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle alors des drones
survolent des centrales nucléaires oui
bah oui mais enfin enfin enfin le retour
de yann arthus bertrand qui signe son
come back avec son livre l'atome vue du
ciel alors est pas belle la vie
ici
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu